cae otro objetivo de la región de
donnietsk eso fue lo que reportó el
Ministerio de defensa ruso que afirma
haber tomado el control de la localidad
de piski
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continúan una operación militar
especial en Ucrania como resultado del
avance de las fuerzas rusas y prorusas
piski en la República Popular de doñets
ha sido completamente liberada cerca de
krama torch en la República Popular de
doñets un sistema de cohetes y Mars y un
depósito con municiones fueron
destruidos
precisamente cohetes rusos alcanzaron
cromatorsk el viernes en la noche
causando la muerte a tres personas y
dejando 11 heridos jalina asegura haber
sobrevivido por estar guarecido en su
casa
es bueno si estuviéramos en la calle no
estoy segura de que pudiéramos hablar
con usted ahora todos los elementos de
los proyectiles están en el patio el
hecho de que estuviéramos dentro de la
casa nos salvó solo esto
tras los ataques que no cesan y la
guerra que ya completa casi seis meses
el presidente bolodimir selensky insiste
en el bloqueo a Rusia y a sus ciudadanos
en primer lugar se debe garantizar que
los asesinos rusos y los Cómplices del
terrorismo de estado no puedan usar las
visas schen en segundo lugar la idea de
Europa en sí misma no puede destruirse
nuestros valores europeos comunes no
pueden destruirse lo que significa que
no podemos a Europa en un supermercado
donde no importa quien venga Lo único
que importa es que se paguen las compras
entre tanto Moscú advirtió a Washington
que si Estados Unidos convierte en ley
la propuesta de proyecto presentado en
la cámara de representantes que pide
declarar a Rusia como un estado
patrocinador del terrorismo las
relaciones bilaterales se destruirían
por completo